[Music]
Tomas a Adama come laser davekeli Romer
Seema Oh Lee club or organization where
the seven-mile a possibility participate
OSI fund as a la fundación McConnell
pour an artist pass you know a loan to Z
Azam California's hear my demo tape
orders to sue J law school Feynman
prayer expose a bizarre Larimar cake
yes attention watch monster matheson the
palais de la situación a Cell the Peter
say normal novel collaborate Rafa
yonsama Ponder's about the Christian
descend on a new Jean trabajado sooraj
collective on some don't say no milk pot
a certain perspective may become M
aboard a lake has to imported we denote
fasten way avec de de the question
whether the is analyse and per different
food on a in gam da da fastened upon say
innovation way inclusive associate don't
my presentation commissar party da Costa
Luke premier Costa a okay okay the
premier cons cons - a k fo ferritin co
and certainly small dollar disco politic
on a day they discover a the protective
his a bleep over at a Dante's action
anti-poverty Asian of critique a and
la prevención de la pauvre ta Pomona
femme mon pere milà peg and in strategy
anti-poverty Nagao Parnassus emma
addresses on automatic la promoción the
legality a pourquoi particle is a Galit
in a gala taste on to short pluriel
honor the illegality they passed the
legality the revenue a don't see later
ooh-la societal severe loot contra la
poverty you know loot Parnassus Irma
contra lays out in a gala take long
sealer lingerie legality a diploma voir
legality before veritasium essays out in
a gala take his song trick on you while
premier salad distribution the revenue
say per unique mark Norman Thomas la
distribution so say in in in a gala take
an old cell is illegality de pouvoir
prove associate prove our politics every
latina Galit a the participation la
participation a la vie politic
don associate a cv Donna V so CL on
general ap Illya Obinna male Xena
garroted a chance unequal opportunities
a security capabilities don't a try
become capacity don't the politic public
EVs and amelioration de la situación paw
report
I was in a garret a a legal it a dwarf
grande roue and cold season against a
say DiMaggio additional color DiMaggio
the revenue long sustained premier
Consta nauseam co-star Sekulow and vrai
unit and regime a ray inclusio social
demand priests to participation for a
div a legality so on dude Michigan ba
bamp Ali Devon Taj Mae
Java Metroid 11 second star curly
politique small de la soirée politics
Oceania and general dwell de Paz alien
streamer politic both whisker sulamita
alluro distribution the revenue it was
like you pay the laser diamond in a gala
tesserae say a soup wallah capito cetera
a on pollen you see the set necessitate
the de passe and an attention exclusive
silica see on revenue if we have what is
innovation sociology from of legality
entre fermium entre group socio entre
class - a and C thus we don't don't
reveal a debut Timon place a token stat
George the food rape pourquoi je voulais
[ __ ] like a shampoo quality' d'oeuvre
tip remove wall and clothes on sociology
legality she commands a super nova
scotia sweet polly to log the polluted
stock cube Suva Delita
don't you commence to Georgia they are
away an associate a severely for pirate
reponse ears may want on computer log
later and Rosa comma say back later
don't poo quality' a peek past occur no
Zeta theta Quebec wallet a Canadian
assorted own the people to see as an a
pretty common objective in second
promotional inclusion associate and ma
mmm the legality don't wanna pour upon
recitation pourquoi on a procedure
tiptoe a poem so they are to the pelagic
at cheap yet is argument Kimmy soul
immorality allege juste Juniper merit AC
persuasion sweeper first off a Jeep Ram
por aqui collage you see Scioscia demand
said sergeant activity yollie's argument
Pollock leafy casita
in certain avoid inclusion social
protest like Oh easy on sosial
yes you'll instability a lucky day on
our tonsil varnish and alguma pourquoi
fo sock you pay promote provoke remove
wall and kruseman associate say an
argument Vala become the premier LLC
lays argument key missile is advantage
economic dual inclusive associate a
seaport at leprechaun new sailor levered
Kate Packard a Richard Wilkinson loggia
Marcus a pea
the dilemma tail is in the galley tape a
Scalise associate a loser galley tears
on please I know that trees on my chair
the economic Asante etc Catriona tipped
arguments in our democracy necessary
poor ereve adult la cañada pre-med
nineties and on a lab or laser uma an
term the legality a payer say necessary
nuvvula of wall equations equations
inclusive nacet and then satan Givaudan
Vestas ma socio don't the presents a
true concern a pourquoi monday dinner
gala teh Profeta tubes age plus elastic
to de nouveau Mendonsa Tajima dulcet
position to próxima semana pasado de
Menezes argument upon scale on 3 ec c
donk
Vasile a little dog you ma may see on
only marginally alleys are you MA see ya
is argument pourquoi
um passe like as Joan the Kelso Lizzy no
- yo sociologist feel a poor Polly
innovative associate Geneva no suit a
poor quality navazio sociale
Kherson is inverse no social inclusion
Scioscia
legality a on tanka prof asian-fusion
continuation politic definition Paseo
cerca de Parfum donk honor in definition
the Dana version so she al says vasila
definition de Lune european dunk
Bhupati elderly or beaucoup blue vehicle
'dear
dong-soo Beulah's leer la definition de
Lune european here to tell is a mat na
Don Tuesday program keys on a la folie
program do Luna on Tonka tell a Cal
premier o played a Zeta mom reporter on
courage a innovation social sukima
frappe Casey on prana definition de la
fundación McConnell on for a school mem
definition Thomson definition Trey
pottage a thirty-day college innovation
social so dizzy day they provided a
service Nouveau siccolas institutions
lay prop or Nouveau parsec oh oh not a
problem socio virgin non c'est pas Supra
no later on to the mall mmm
this tanks Yong su casa da just put this
tanguay on Paseo de finish you know I
could Donatella definition de Lune
european new voyages telefon de la cita
see on your part definition part delle
Mele ostium they said this socio
don't say a leader the social services
only through fun SSM on Donovan - you
know and definition fundació McConnell
polonaise don't race am Loki a loon
Europeans a and groovin amar and cassia
taught on dis California McConnell say
and fundación work he has she done the
Donna sector Scioscia don't let me
lately they Denova say kfo imagine a
before therefore develop a if Oh II know
they only to listen evasion Pune is only
for f-word less less experienced super
una interpolate a alone European a Donna
funda soon come McConnell on part and
parlayed scaling up on commands directly
pros a pilot a on ferry ladies
experienced a on are even owed nouveau
don't say second sake of Japan see for
Paul say from a for parcel is innovation
Scioscia the Vaudreuil just a merit a
seaport in minute Papa later Kelly
lightly attacked the Rockets John
Donley's etude kiante TFA iron a son
dude Buchanan's a Trebbia Lamberto says
say say say to dongjun the pam merit a
troll oncology may Illya Japan's honor
guard on leg stereo yes certainly sunken
tier a Vanessa same I am poet Emily let
some comfort here a the state's example
[ __ ] Morales purple okay back April
Canada Ezra Buddha paladin
Dan publication recent quiete saying
document or shares capably a paddock a
leg arrow pea is unfair nature days
innovation so she had dumped Lucy air
veal or opened on the number of
important reveal her opinion a look the
ground conclusions so Korea from Emma
they sabotage important Lee a regime
mixed Duncan mix entre well kid and a
collaboration through sector public
sector Prive associate a Seville don't
put and group kombucha Chaka
Vasavada geometry travaille lumpur tones
de collaboration departing area etc mace
attitude the comparison Donovan open de
menthe Libre Zevon Taj Tandy los los lay
sector collab our only vote finis ma
mail Co Nevada libras are the service a
Japan's could say and massage compare
our caliper upon say divan Tasha so to
donate excuse description give a veneer
but now I want to move to the question
of what what kinds of of social
innovations might be the most useful in
here I'm going to make a third
proposition which is that the public
policies that are going to really
advance equality in the multiple
dimensions that I'm that I talked about
at the beginning have to have three legs
it has to be a as stool with three legs
and I'm going to illustrate this with
two examples of in social innovations
which are currently much discussed and
I'm going to point to some of the limits
of only have not had paying attention to
the three legs so the first that as I
said the characteristics are that they
have to incorporate incorporate elements
which help people to be more resilient
and help societies to be more democratic
because more debt more societies which
are more inclusive and demonstrate more
cat and and excuse me societies which
are more democratic are also more
egalitarian and so this how can this
three-legged stool be be brought about
and so for my for my two examples I want
to talk about an innovation which is
very recent and and one which is merely
being discussed so this kind of
innovation for a social inclusion
involves a redistribution of revenues
one of the legs of
the stool certainly but it also involves
new rights and it involves new services
and here again I'm coming over onto the
same territory as Peter so let's think
about the first examples the new bit
child benefit that was announced in the
budget in 2016 this is a great policy
instrument I I'm not critical of it at
all I agree with the evaluation that the
ministers have made it's going to reduce
poverty and is going to increase income
okay we accept that but will it do
anything for equality and this is where
I have a more skeptical and more
critical set of comments I think that it
will do something about inequality of
income but it's much more limited in
terms of whether it will affect the
distribution of power and the
distribution of resources between
families so it's a one legged stool and
what would be a more appropriate
division this the this the second leg of
the stool would be to provide access to
services and here I'm not going to
rehash the well-known arguments about
why we need childcare and affordable
childcare and accessible childcare and
why that has to be of good quality as
well as as existing but the the without
the the addition of the element of
childcare services the redistribution of
income remains limited why because as
this chart tells you if you could read
it is that the distribution of childcare
costs are extremely uneven and childcare
outside of Quebec is extremely expensive
so that the 2300 increase in income will
basically give a family in Toronto two
months of childcare according to the Act
the cost of it so it's it's going to
increase our income it's going to give
them two months but two months is not 12
months two months is not 11 months if we
think about vacations so new services
and do n rights parental leave is not
part of this
this change there's they're beginning to
talk maybe about a father's allowance
and there's nothing about family
allowances and we know from Quebec that
adding in those kinds of benefits of
return 'ti benefits and access to
parental benefits wider access has
increased the sharing of work within the
family or the sharing of parenting
within the family and these have had
real consequences and these these the
differences between Quebec and the other
provinces demonstrate that the addition
of new rights along with new income and
along with new services can change the
inequalities within a society so that we
know these things and therefore my
criticism of the federal government's
policy is that it only has one leg and
not three let's look at another example
this much discussed the example of a
basic income and the prime prime
minister of Quebec has has talked about
it the minister of children families
children Social Development has talked
about having a guaranteed minimum income
does this pass my test is this a
three-legged stool and innovation
obviously it's an instrument for
redistributing income or at the lower
end of the of the ladder but does it do
anything about equality for a basic
income to be a social innovation I and
that would what a social innovation that
would increase social inclusion and
reduce inequalities it would have to be
accompanied by changes in public
services and rights and that these
themselves would have to be seen to be
innovations once again simply changing
the distribution is insufficient it
doesn't make it three-legged what would
these innovations be this is where you
people come in because it involves a new
canoe imagination
imagining new kinds of services and new
kinds of right it involves imagining for
example how to increase the access to
participation and new voices for those
who are who are marginalized and it in
it involves imagining how these this
kind of mixed system of welfare that I
talked about is the lesson from the
European book how that would be brought
about this hat tare foot takes a lot of
experimentation and I'm the academic so
I'm gonna cop out here and I'm gonna say
what I want what I needed is rather than
telling you what to do is I need you to
think about the the ways in which the
mixed regimes of welfare the that the
participation of these sectors can be
combined to provide services services
that promote equality between age groups
how can we include an sure social
inclusion for the young and for the
elderly how to include them in into
democratic life what are the necessary
accompanying services and and what is
the role of each of the actors in this
what would the mixed regime of welfare
look like to break isolation to improve
access to employment what are the rights
that would be necessary in terms of
housing how can that be brought about
and to to work these are just examples
but that's the questions that I think
that that we need to address is how to
do it when we but that with the lesson
them the message I want to leave with
you is that a one legged public policy
is inadequate it depends on those other
two legs and very often those other two
legs come from the kinds of mixed
regimes of welfare that are represented
in the room and therefore I hope in the
discussion we'll be able to think about
how to get those other two legs attached
and move forward thank you
[Applause]
[Music]